[Music]  [Music]  to see you there crying boy  [Music]  to mind  [Music]  all the things i told you  one  time  [Music]  i told you she'd hurt you  and leave more regret  [Music]  and more heartache  than you could ever forget  so sit there and cry  the way that i did one time  [Music]  the way that she made me new  [Music]  yes i know what you're going through  and i feel you  [Music]  when you took her from me  you thought you'd found  the woman  to build your whole world around  i tried to tell you  what you wouldn't see  [Music]  should leave you for someone like she  did me  now sit there and cry  [Music]  [Applause]  to get that woman off of your mind  the way that she made me do  i know what you're going through  and i feel for you  i know what you're going through  and i feel for you  [Music]